yeah you don't know how to make money
and okay yeah you like have a lot of
insecurities still and you're not
through it yet you're struggling with
depression because your upbringing
created a very negative framework of
insecurity and happiness and jealousy
that's okay we're all working through
[__] how many more days how many more
weeks how many more months how many more
years are you interested in walking
around this Earth not feeling good find
more positive people find more positive
content you're delusional I like keeping
it real you keep it real negative what
the [__] is real there's no real there's
your reality oh man ladies and gentlemen
Gary Vader shot good to see you brother
thank you Stephen dude it's been a year
or so since we got to hang out before it
has I apologize I'm sending this link to
the Discord so people can join let's do
it you know um first of all thank you
this has been very fun for me but two
podcasts with you have been incredible
the community that that I've been
working with just loves your content
loves to be with you and so I got some
good stuff for you today I can't wait
we're gonna dive in it's been really
really a fun Journey doing this with you
dude let's rock man so we're gonna start
30 000 up in the air and then we're
gonna come right down to the ground at
the end and then I got some fun stuff to
surprise you with so
mortgage industry is a mess okay coming
out of covid we had the best years in
lending in real estate of all time rates
drop to the bottom incredible industry
went to a four trillion dollar industry
overnight and everybody became
Superstars right
last year rude awakening total
Readjustment back to normalcy but now
normalcy doesn't feel normal
and lots of people lost their jobs lots
of stuff happened and negativity like it
always does in the Press just dominated
yes everywhere so the first place I want
to start with you on is just you talk a
lot about positivity yes but nobody's
immune to the bad stuff in life it just
happens in business in in like well okay
okay everything and everything so
if someone's dealing with this Market
the chaos the the Press what advice do
you have to stay positive how do you
frame up around that
well I think in the context that you
just brought this up in like
positivity
um can't be delusional that's a good
comment you know yeah and so for me I'm
not looking for some sort of like hope
and delusion and fantasy land but I also
think that positivity needs to be fair
and here's what I mean by that
um you know most people are incredibly
incredibly naive if they think that
their work life
needs to be the reality of their
positivity meaning how do I deal with it
if you're in this in the mortgage
business and your business is down right
now
did you practically save when you had
the best two years like did yeah did you
make more money than ever during covid
and then take that money and buy a boat
or a goo or 8 000 pieces of Gucci that
might have been a bad idea if you didn't
understand like well
you know this is kind of like inflated
once in a lifetime reality and
eventually things are going to normalize
and things that go up so fast tend to
come down so fast
there's that then there's also like are
you really complaining about having less
money yeah because I think you know the
reason I tend to stay positive is I have
a really interesting relationship with
money which is
I didn't grow up with a lot of it
I worked from 22 to 34 all the time to
build something for my father yeah and
mother so I wasn't compensated in
reality towards the impact I was making
and so I lived humbly by the standards
of society yeah
um and you know it's not my driving
force I've also never spent money to put
myself in a vulnerable position yeah and
so you know for example let's say you
did okay cool Gary but what about me
okay let's talk about you you had two
great years in mortgage life and made a
lot more money than ever and then you
decided to sell your house and buy a new
house absolutely happens all the time
story all the time right and now you're
feeling the pain because you're not
making as much money and even the
mortgage payments even at a low rate
absolutely are too much because you went
over your skis
I say to you if you're my best friend
sell your house
sell your house and go to a lesser house
sell your house and rent for a little
while yep but you know what friends says
in that scenario I don't have the mental
strength to go backwards that's a very
that's absolutely true right I Gary
you're my best friend we've been
together you know Robbie turnick Brandon
warnicky I I'm talking about people in
my life uh it's not their realities I'm
just saying in general I person don't
have the mental strength to go backwards
why because I flexed well so my new
house bro it's not just that right
people's production double tripled and
now their production's normalizing but
that's not their identity anymore in
their head they're still the mega
Superstar and it is a humble pie once
you fall in love with humility
you have a chance of being happy yeah
and so you know humility is not at the
expense of confidence
and ambition I'm all sorts of confident
and ambitious
I also have the humility to realize I'm
not special
I also have the humility and the and the
self-confidence to not need outside
affirmation
and so you know when I hear you start
this conversation in the context of
mortgage professionals who made a ton of
money and right now aren't like I don't
I struggle with
the heavy negativity being a financial
situation yeah because if you crushed
the last two years you seemingly have
the opportunity
to eat a lot of Humble Pie and reset
including well Gary I didn't buy a house
yeah and so I can't down trade I bought
a lot of stuff absolutely sell your
stuff like if you bought an 8 000
handbag
that in hindsight you wish you had eight
thousand sell it for 6 700 on eBay yep
people want their cake and eat it too
and that's why they have issues I say
Lean Into You Know accountability yeah
and address the situation well some of
the stuff too is we kind of move into
the next question here
um the stuff that drove their success in
a great market and even the markets
before it aren't working now
and there's there's a whole change in
the world today I mean you've been a big
Pioneer of social media you've been
understanding where attention's at yep
and so one of my favorite talking points
you have is this thing of slow down the
macro and speed up the micro
and people get confused on this because
you talk a lot about patients too and
they think that means well I should just
go slow well for some reason people have
decided to turn the word patience into
passiveness that's yeah why are they why
do the two words exist when I say be
patient I don't mean lay on your couch
and watch TV I mean I'm gonna stand up
people don't understand this clip that
Dustin so if someone's never heard the
Slowdown the macro speed up the micro
what does that mean expand that for a
second
your day-to-day like you know I don't
know like we're gonna do this together
in real time because I like jamming with
you like like you you even laughed a
little bit Julian said I following
around like something that was like a
five minute transition like this is my
calendar yeah like it's constant yeah
and by the way this is look at these
meetings just what does that say 11 to
1105 five minute meeting 11 05 to 11 30
11 30 11 45 11 45 to 12 1205 to 12 15 12
15 to 12 30. I did
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve Thirty I did 15 meetings
before 1 pm today okay so the reason is
15 minutes so that's speed up your micro
your day-to-day go way faster be way
more efficient but macro I'm not in a
rush to buy the New York Jets I love my
process I'm not in a rush to buy a Lambo
or a house like everyone needs to really
really really really really
speed up their day-to-day
but slow their skis on their big goals
enjoy the process don't rush to get the
trophy yeah it's my favorite thing when
talking to my sales team is you know I'm
not having the success I want I go great
let me see your calendar
it doesn't look like that it doesn't
look like that there's all these Pockets
so I mean people like like literally I
had 12 meetings before one o'clock today
real ones real business meetings yeah to
your point there are people I see people
in the chat I know you're going back and
forth yeah like that really don't have
12 meetings in a week yes and that's
okay this is not judgment no it's just
commentary yeah of course it's like by
the way I I envy it sometimes you know
I'm a human being you don't think
sometimes in my 19th living by noon I'm
like you know um yes I had the DNA that
would have been like all about you know
a different and by the way this is why I
know it to be true I can't help it it's
what makes me happy
that like I'm almost like the reverse of
a lot of people
like I kind of like secretly dream about
wishing that I was super basic and had
happiness in that there's a six-sided
it's like I'm romantic about people who
have found tremendous happiness and
simplicity because I love that I have it
mentally but I don't have it actually
yeah and so I like that now there are
some you guys asking if you ask
questions and yes you can although
there's tons of commentary coming in so
we'll do our best to get to some
questions and I do have some special
questions at the end
um but I want to keep coming down the
channel good job we were at like are you
checking this number right now the
little push yeah yeah I had to give you
a little bit garyvee effect it's all
good 30 to 12 30 is a good run
all right so I want to hit come I'm
circling on patience with you here okay
social media patients instant
gratification world we live in yes I
mean it's just true everyone wants it
now we want it now all day long that's
called entitlement
so
people especially in my industry now
there's waking up to the reality that
social media is going to matter okay and
they're trying to find their voice in
the game makes sense and we talked about
this a year ago in the first podcast
when it was the The Wine Library TV
Clips yes all the clips you did that no
one cared about did a good job with that
I appreciate that so I I find people
consistently need some kind of message
or encouragement to stay consistent to
stay the game when they're not getting
engagement not getting likes not getting
what they think they should get I
for the I started working out very
seriously at 38 and a half
I'm like a six-year-old man and a half
in there but it's the truth I was 30 and
a half when I started working out
consistently
I have only for the first time outside
of a huge pump on a chest day
in the last three months have noticed
that I have chest muscles yes that like
literally will have you know got out of
the shower looked like and I'm like wait
a minute hey hey
holy [__] it's happening it's happening
I'm I am eight nine years into this
journey
I'm nine years into this journey nine
years it took me
of like real working out to finally have
some tiny there's people born with more
chest muscle than I have right now it's
true what what I would say is like look
I don't understand how you don't
understand that anything meaningful and
good takes real time and effort yeah
like I just don't like wouldn't it be
logical
that if it only took nine days or nine
months we got it to get to the top that
everyone would do it yep 100 that's
[__] hard yeah it's hard it's hard
but it's worth it
love is hard worth it right
relationship's hard worth it like we
have to get out of this entitlement
like as if living
entitles you for it
you have to work for it listen I have to
work for it like I've had to work I
don't have the book here somewhere 12
and a half like I've gotten better
because I've leaned into Candor yeah
I've had to work at it yeah and you were
honest about it I've had to work at it
it's come so not natural to me I still
hate it I will always hate it because
delivering something negative in theory
to someone is like like it kills me but
like I don't know what to tell people
like it is what it is like if you would
like to have something of meaning you're
gonna have to put in a lot of work for a
very long time my whole thing is instead
of thinking you're gonna hit a lottery
ticket why don't you do what I do and
other people that I admire do which is
this is gonna take me 57 years
and actually believe it like I have and
just sitting it sitting it somebody had
a really interesting talk with me the
other day who like actually started off
by hating me and thinking like oh your
parents like was kind of this person
like Gary's dad and like somehow met
someone that was the uh his neighbor was
like 80 years old and like knew the
whole story like worked with my dad like
knew the story yeah yeah the truth
and like broke it down and it kind of
got the guy like completely 360 on me
and then I ran into the guy at an
airport and he like had a few minutes
with me and we really talked about he's
like now that I understand that you
actually
built the business for your dad in a lot
of way or took it to it listen my dad
built it my dad is the American dream
came here with nothing and built a local
but but I really did something for my
dad and he said to me how did you like
really like the reason I never believed
it was I just don't believe how a 22
year old will work every day seven days
a week for 12 years and have nothing
yeah and I was like it wasn't nothing
you think money's the thing yeah you I
had satisfaction that I'm gonna go to
the Grave giving back to the parents who
brought me to this country right who
built me who loved me who put a roof
like I gave back
giving is the ultimate getting yeah
right so you know when I talk about
patience
I worked the first 12 years of my career
to financially incentivize my parents
yeah
so of course I believe in patients I was
34 when I kind of started for myself
yeah so I think that people are really
confused and because I had 57 years when
I was 22 and I'm like when I'm 79 I'll
get to what I got it and I at 22. well
then all of a sudden you can imagine why
12 years didn't feel like [__] when
everyone's like I'm gonna be a
billionaire by the time I'm 30. well no
[__] you're freaking the [__] out at 24.
and you're like that's far from a
billion like and I only got six years
I'm 47 I'm like chilling I'm like is it
halftime yet like like there's I'm at
the two minute warning of the first half
I'm chilling over here two great quotes
from you
reputation is the ultimate currency
and social media is grossly underpriced
attention yeah
someone today getting inspired and going
okay I get this I believe in I'm ready
and this is more tactical like this is
coming down a little bit down to the
street but like what is going all in
look like today doing the push-ups
today you decided that you want to check
a check right yes and I would say drop
to the floor and do a good push-up
[Music]
in the version that you're asking it
means take your phone flip it over and
talk about something you know or you're
passionate about yes something you know
or something you're passionate about you
want the framework of success something
you know
I will talk about wine or the Jets or
something you're passionate about be
nice to each other
no
passion no
passion and do that as many times as you
humanly can good until the end
and you've talked about
um it's irrelevance
think about good enough
well what is good enough right like to
your point you don't know this is back
to loving yourself you don't know you're
good enough until you do it yeah
yeah
I mean look but to your point so I had a
really good friend who
picked up the camera and started to get
in the game and I'm and he's a
tremendous professional he's got it all
down like he doesn't and he's good
looking too it's like [__] you guys all
of it it's got it all of it and a buddy
of his gave him gave him crap and said
dude this isn't you and he called me up
and he goes is it not me and I don't
think he my answer he didn't like it
right away because I said of course it's
not you you're so uncomfortable it's not
you yet it's not that you you me hanging
out having a beer like and and now I
watch him dude he's relaxed he's on it
says and it's it's real raps
what thing on earth
have people not gotten better at after
they've done it a good trillion times
yeah
cap yeah but like you like I just I
don't
I you know even with Dustin go back to
so I love that and go back to what
Dustin just said like I don't want
anybody to judge if they're good enough
at it but to his point one of the things
that people like you know that whole
thing of like the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and not and expecting a different result
yeah like people like garyvee I made
1700 this happens sometimes I've made
1700 videos and I'm still getting 49
views I'm like yo we just talked about
it you know like we should talk about
this like you've proven to me and
yourself and the world that you're not
interesting at this right now you're not
bringing value to people whether you
know and value comes in all shapes
modeling is an amazing thing you were
born and you were valuable like like
right awesome look by the way
you still have to work at it I love when
people are like like if you were
naturally attractive and you do not eat
well and do not work out it's going to
be okay exactly uh you are naturally
funny yes but I think all of us have
watched documentaries on comedians where
it's very clear no different than what
you just said that they needed a lot of
ref yeah in small comedy shops before
they became [__] Kevin Hart that's
right and there's layers you get
coaching you get you learn how to yes
there's layers to all this stuff but
this is a good question I want to hit
this one because it's in line how do you
succeed in doing videos on things you
know are passionate if somebody else is
already in and succeeding at it nobody
else is winning is coming out of yours
if that was true the game was over a
long time ago that's right why did
LeBron try to pass Kareem oh Kareem was
the all-time leading scorer yeah like
why is Kevin Hart doing that Eddie
Murphy did that already but why did
Eddie Murphy do that Richard Pryor
already did yeah what are we talking
about here this Con excuses like that
and notice the word I used excuses like
that are just people that are scared to
do the thing and fail on Merit they feel
better that somebody already took it
the world is abundant if you're good
enough
no matter how much is already taken you
can get yours too
I wasn't the first person to talk about
kindness I was the first person to talk
about work I wasn't the first person to
talk about technology that is a
ludicrous point of view and I come from
a place of compassion when I use that
statement that person needs to realize
that's a subconscious excuse to not do
yeah and it's better to blame that oh
they didn't get lucky somebody already
did it versus them having to put in the
work to do it did I get the same Vibe
and I talk to people because there's I'm
I'm on video and I'm I'm big on video I
have a lot of I'm loud I'm wearing
costumes I do a lot of weird stuff and
then there's the engineer who's sitting
down and explaining line by line through
a complicated mortgage document both
those people have tremendous audience
capacities huge and they're needed
sometimes you need to escape and be
entertained to learn I fall in that
category yeah I want to entertain to
trick you into the thing yes yes other
times people need a little people come
at me all the time they're Gary any more
details so when I put out the dollar
eighty strategy or even that little
thing I just did the reason I did it
three times I'm like oh that's a little
bit more tangible able that I normally
go either talk about something you know
or something you're passionate about
that's like that will land for some
people it will and like to your point
like it all comes in all shapes and
sizes some people really like to read
800 pages of the technical person I
would die but you would not survive but
God no no die if somebody wants you
right now you have to read these 800
pages of electrical engineering and if
you don't you'll die I'm like just kill
me right now
all right so I did something fun uh with
my community you know Gary lots of
people want to access to you and you
know you're busy
um and you love q a I've seen with this
stuff so I asked um some of my buddies
on the internet if they have a question
for you I love it record it let's do it
I'll play it and so I got some people
that jumped in let's go so let's let's
hit you some questions what happened to
daily Vlogs and do you see them making a
comeback in 2023 great question yeah my
boy we're filming one right now yeah I
do see it coming back I don't know if
you heard but there was this thing
called covid I'm weird yeah Google it
c-o-v-i-d it was a thing it happened it
kind of [__] up the flow uh but I
think we'll be back and I expect by
2024. I mean I'm I can sense myself
getting close by the way you get out of
practice that's true dust how many
things have I said I don't want to film
that would have been insane I would have
been upset if you didn't film three
years ago true really out of practice
Yeah out of practice you just got to get
back into practice but yeah I think I
think we are going to be more than bad
daily B so you think the blog space
personal blog space is going to start
that people should pay attention to that
potentially for their own business and
branding and marketing efforts yeah
documenting over creating I mean it's
everything yeah I like it all right
let's this one's a long-winded question
I tried to close it down but here we go
three years in as a full-time real
estate agent I sell about 26 houses per
year the bulk of my leads comes from
leads delivery platforms like
realtor.com Op City where you get the
leads for free up front but then you
have to pay a 35 referral fee out of
your commission once you've closed the
deal on the back end so I'm in like the
top one and a half percent in the
Midwest region I do very well with this
model I've incubated my business but I
want to go to the next level where I get
more customers on my own I don't have to
pay that fee on the back end I pay up
front I invest early on and I try to get
the leads on my own so I either have to
create the content myself and sort of
cowboy and figure out how to deploy that
concept properly or I can use a website
company that can provide me an idx fed
website they can create the the Google
search queries and Facebook ads they can
Contour uh landing pages specific to
those search queries and ads and bring
in the leads so that I can focus on
closing deals it costs about thirteen
hundred dollars a month to do this and
with the uncertainty in our current
market economy what's going on in the
next six to eight months I don't know is
this the right time to to throw the
money at it and have a company do it for
me or should I be sort of holding onto
my budget and try to be a little bit
more frugal learn how to Cowboy it and
try to snowball on my own uh obtaining
leads that's my question both are fine
by me I'd prefer him do it himself
because I
learn a lot more yeah
the math that I just read at 1300 bucks
a month
35 percent commission on one deal in
theory on like an average house puts you
in the math
people are funny yeah people are funny
well and when I when I heard that from
my boy it's
I think there's a space for both but I
also think like you do this a lot too
you got to play in the in the in the
meat to figure it out yes the dirt
matters like you gotta you gotta make
your own videos and publish your own
stuff and watch and learn how to do it
what's interesting about him if you
think about it he's like really
interested in giving up economics
to not do a certain thing which is okay
but there's a lot of people like that of
course that's why we have plastic
surgery there's a reason lipo happens
you don't want to do the four years of
the gym and eating healthy you don't
want to [__] put in the work yeah
which is fine by the way he might be
right it might be worth the Arbitrage
yeah I think the problem is is okay it's
35 commission now here's the problem
when you don't have the leverage yeah
what happens to that guy when
realtor.com tomorrow says it's 50 that's
right what's he gonna say
I guess it is I guess it's 50 now I
don't like that [__] game
when someone else has the Leverage
bad things happen
and as this economy squeezes Amazon and
Google and realtor.com and Zillow and
everybody else is going to say well we
don't like our numbers you know what
we're going to do we're gonna take a
bigger piece of the cut yep and
everybody who's been sucking off that
teat
is gonna swallow it because they have no
leverage because they didn't build their
own moat
well and this goes whoever is closest to
the customer has the leverage yeah
you've been saying that for for it feels
like Decades of my life and figuring out
how to get in that strategy zone for
yourself for your own voice is the chord
on controlling your own destiny
otherwise someone's gonna control it for
you
everyone's like [__] social media the
algorithm like you don't even [__]
pay for it
you don't pay for all this captive
audience and it's like it's like
I'm like what like you you're happily
paying 35 commission to realtor but
you're mad that the algorithm is Shadow
Banning you nobody's Shadow Banning you
you [__] just suck at content yes get
better learn watch videos that's my
favorite thing the shadow band I've been
Shadow band I've been chat I'm getting
Shadow banned no you're not you stink
all right let's go here this is an
interesting question Carl I met this guy
through NFC community and Twitter when
Twitter turned into the nft community it
was an amazing period of time
um so this is going to have some layers
to it okay thank you so much for giving
me this great opportunity to be able to
come onto your show and ask the one and
only Gary Fay Nerd Chuck what I believe
to be such an important question being a
foster care Advocate this is actually a
two-part question Gary uh so let's just
jump right into it Gary what piece of
advice do you give kids uh especially to
those in foster care who will be aging
out with no one in their Corner uh
pretty much no support system the second
half of that question how and where can
they access resources people pretty much
mentorships coming from such a
disadvantaged place in order to nurture
that an entrepreneurial Spirit again
Alec thank you and Gary thanks so much
uh for taking the time to answer this
Carl I think this is one of my favorite
questions I'm a big believer that the
perceived negative is actually the
positive yeah so let's break it down
I believe that the world is actually in
people's Corner way more than we think
and I'm very aware of like you know
racism anti-Semitism yeah like real
separation of wealth There's real stuff
but humans
day-to-day humans are actually
remarkable like remarkable people like
like 90 of the 8 billion like have
General good intent or at least somewhat
neutral and if you give them any reason
to have compassion they'll go there yeah
so for example
the perceived disadvantage is the
advantage
million emails really like 10 to 50 000
but 10
emails
a month a year yeah a lot
saying help me give me time help me give
me time
if if I saw a titled email like I was
brought up in the foster care system can
you give me five minutes to talk there's
a far higher likelihood that I'll say
yes to that yeah than me it was like hey
Gary you know it's just like yeah bro no
I think that the world collectively
agrees that coming up the foster care
system is a really really challenging
starting point to a life yeah I would
argue that I've met at least a half a
dozen to a dozen people at this point
just you know not a lot but plenty yeah
to have an observation that for many of
them it's a tremendous Advantage because
of the chip on the shoulder and I would
argue some of them have been fortunate
enough to have multiple people in their
corner
people like you meet people right
many people wish they didn't have their
parents in their corner all he's really
saying is they didn't have parents many
people actually lost by growing up with
bad parenting that's not good comment
right so who's worse
who's better
and so what I would say is the the
reality is is that narrative is going to
capture most people's heart most people
today in 2023 if you say to them I grew
up in a middle class family but my mom
was or my dad was X Y and Z and I'm
deeply insecure they'd be like all right
it'll be like a kind of like a quick
two-minute Converse like that's
something okay at least you were middle
class you weren't poorer they'll go
somewhere meanwhile the person that's
deeply insecure
knows how [__] bad that was yeah and
like can't function in society meanwhile
you tell anybody hey I grew up in the
foster care said you have deep
compassion deep default support ready to
support so I think I think that's what's
interesting about these kind of
conversations and I I think the where do
they go I think they DM and reach out to
people yeah and they say I grew up in
the foster care system you have 10
minutes for me and I think they're gonna
get a lot more yeses than they think
Mark Cuban is going to say yes to that
email more likely than the normal one
yeah I believe that Oprah is going to
say yes to that one but like you can
shoot for the stars and it goes back to
the Reps DM for the answer to every
question is DM 4000 people
direct message 4 000 people and get
three people to say yes but you know
what happens
they don't want to DM 4 000 people yeah
or they DM me once I don't reply and
they're like [__] you you run that
[__] YouTube you said to the bro I
didn't see it exactly come on a little
bit of it drock asked for his job seven
times or three times right like just
YouTube you applied more than what right
twice not bad uh you know like but like
but you know how many people stop at one
everyone
people wouldn't start they stop at zero
yeah I I want to hit this a little
deeper because I loved how you framed it
you know your story is your superpower
I've watched people who said I I can't I
don't speak English well the second
language and they don't want to get
videos they don't need videos because
their English is broken in their mind
I'm so empathetic for that because my
parents no question stayed more private
in their lives because they were
embarrassed of their accent it was a
very common 80s 90s thing but I've
watched this I've watched some of these
people turn that into their superpower
because there's a billion people that
English is their second language and
they go so all of a sudden this person
who's putting themselves out there in a
position of vulnerability becomes
somebody they can connect with and that
the know you like you trust you think
builds and then that's what they want to
do business with everybody wins on their
uniqueness and everyone's insecure about
their uniqueness yes yes say it again
for those in the back
everybody wins on their uniqueness but
everyone's insecure of their uniqueness
like the thing that you're like everyone
people haven't figured out like this
thing we grew up with back in the day of
like normal doesn't exist who's what's
normal
like your interests your circumstances
your disabilities your learning
disabilities your challenges if you like
magic the Gathering cards what about you
know the Dungeons and Dragons with deep
like all this [__] friend did I have
that like you know actually spilled hot
tea on myself when I was five and don't
have any markings and it was like really
inner thought like it was really sky was
in hospital for two days I don't talk
about it a lot actually not sure I've
ever talked about it
but because that happened and like it I
got very fortunate that's what I was
always told as a kid like this cream in
a blue bottle it worked and like magic
cream and I was like oh my God the
Russian thing and like and so like I
always thought I was so lucky but that
made me super hypersensitive to kids
that burnt themselves uh and had like
big scars in her arms or her waist and
her meanwhile if you have like a big
burn Scar from like tea all over your
arm right now that is actually your
unique point of differentiation yeah and
the hundreds of thousands of people that
also have a burn mark that may want to
buy a house or may want to buy wine or
may want to like like like like
your thing is your thing you know people
I'll give you another one I always I
don't know why this always caught my
attention people that have birthmarks oh
yeah that are very substantial
especially like in their hair or on
their face these are strengths
I get that you especially if you're my
age where like picking on people was
like just currency yes like whatever you
were just saying you know like and you
know now there's more compassion but
it's different and it's done in a
different way but it's the same [__]
um you know I just think it's a place of
strength and we need to teach people
those uniquenesses are a place of
strength yeah
it is
well look dude first of all thank you
Lynch says unfortunately everyone bring
that up yep gotcha
but Blanche just focus on the people
that are as nice as me because there's a
lot of people like that yeah so many
people will sit and spend all their
energy being upset about the one person
that's making them feel unhappy in class
or in their family or at their workplace
instead of the 37 people that are
sitting in the other side of the house
cheering for them and trying to help
them yeah they put all their energy on
that
instead of the reverse we tend to look
for the negative instead of the
overwhelming positive yep that means
it's work on you you need to do that
work this is not about people being nice
or not nice this is about your ability
to find the nice versus dwelling on the
not nice yeah
yeah and it's worth it I can speak from
a position of you know I was heavily
bullied growing up and coming through
that and finding my own voice has been
an amazingly uh deep freedom
because I just I just I I don't
understand me I still care I don't like
it when someone's mean to me I don't
like when someone talks [__] I don't
like what someone hurts much I'm Still
Human everyone's human even I yeah I'm
like super power at this point yeah but
here's one go deeply deeply quickly into
a feeling bad for them and Watch What
Happens yeah change the narrative people
don't get it right now we're fighting
hate with hate which is why everything
sucks for so many people but yet there's
plenty that's great and you know where
it's great it's when people have hate
thrown at them they combat back with
compassion yep when you throw compassion
at hate
when you when you throw sympathy at hate
when you throw empathy at hate
when you throw up you know what's one
that I don't talk a lot about I when I'm
thrown with hate I default into
appreciation that I'm not widered that
way oh I go into gratitude
I'm so grateful that I don't spend my
time and energy trying to tear down
others at all costs that is like
beautiful how do you accomplish so much
Gary by not focusing on other people
yeah like Leonardo DiCaprio's
relationship status does not [__] up my
life
yeah 100 like [__] Christ already
so hey we're hitting our our time we are
yeah we're 40 already we're cranking bro
you know keep going okay well no so like
we we hit a Leonardo DiCaprio it was
good it was good I was watching people
like
stop care stop [__] worry about your
life for a minute go do some push-ups
we had a lot of ground today you know we
talked about patients positivity and
compassion all these fun things
um there
I just love for you to speak to the
group here from what's on your heart
just kind of whatever message you got
because here's my here's my drive and
maybe you could bring board off this
please
I I wake up inside when I find people
letting go of the [__] and putting
themselves out there to make real human
connections like it's a buzz for me and
I've when people get on video and they
finally start to realize there's an
opportunity for them and their voice
matters and they get maybe it's a little
bit of that affirmation because when I
was bullied now I confirmed somebody
else all that stuff's there
but
you were an unlock for me five four or
five years ago walking having a coffee
in the morning and you say the same
stuff all the time but it was the right
time it was the right time and I went
all in on social I started all in I said
you know this this matters and if I want
to be the leader I want to be I gotta I
gotta be in there too I can't just tell
people to do it I gotta try to play the
game too and I went all in and so it was
a great unlock and it changed the
trajectory of my career and my
relationships and life and all the fun
things
so what message you have to other people
right now that might be ready for the
same step
boy oh boy yeah you know since that kid
that told you those things I think the
last five or six years have evolved
quite a bit into my conviction about the
Simplicity of this all
what do I want to say to everybody
please use this moment this sound clip
this video however you're live right now
for the thousand people on here 850 now
um sorry we lost somebody
um it was Leo Leo coming
stop beating yourself up
let me tell you why every other person
on Earth sucks to
stop putting people on pedestals
don't put your older brother on a
pedestal just because he seemingly has
his [__] together and is winning that
that doesn't mean you suck because I
promise you if you poke hard enough that
older brother that seemingly has all his
[__] together has fears too has hurt too
is struggling too right stop putting
other people in a pedestal not
celebrities not your parents not anyone
that doesn't mean don't have like warm
Affinity towards yeah that doesn't mean
you can't admire of course that doesn't
mean you can't enjoy that doesn't mean
you can't grasp and learn from but don't
put someone on such a pedestal that it
makes you feel lesser than yep
right
start and and more importantly start
really leaning into what you are versus
what you're not yeah I'm thinking about
a lot of people in my life right now who
are just so fixated on what they're not
instead of realizing they're incredibly
loyal yeah they're wildly well intended
they are super great at music
they are a tremendous friend they are
great at cooking okay yeah you don't
know how to make money and okay yeah you
like have a lot of insecurities still
and you're not through it yet okay yeah
like you're you're struggling with
depression because your upbringing
created a very negative framework of
insecurity and happiness and jealousy
that's okay
we're all working through [__] you know
I like had a poison pill in my body
while I thought I was winning everything
it was called lack of Candor yeah
cruising winning by all of your
standards lack of candor
created the only people on earth that
could walk around and not like me
because I wasn't cancerous to them yeah
and I went from the power position of
them [__] up to I'm [__] up because
I wasn't candorous yeah right so there's
a lot to this but like most of all what
am I gonna say
the second you start loving yourself for
real
is the second you'll start doing the
[__] we're talking about here
you're not gonna do [__] if you're
scared
promise you that if you think you're a
piece of [__] you're not making a single
[__] video
not one zero yeah and so
it's time it's [__] time enough like
how many more days how many more weeks
how many more months how many more years
are you interested in walking around
this Earth
and not feeling good
find more positive people find more
positive content
realize what I'm telling you is not an
illusion you're delusional I like
keeping it real you keep it real
negative yeah can you keep it real
there's no real
what's what the [__] is real there's no
real there's your reality
you don't get it of course I don't get
it that's your life you don't get mine
don't you don't get mine I don't get
yours cool
now what
are we in a philosophical standstill
because the next day life's gonna happen
right like I love the debate like
everyone's debating and everyone's
asking everyone to do things
that's also is there something else I
want to leave with stop telling
everybody in the world to do [__] you do
[__]
they should the government should my
boss should my wife should my husband
should my kids should my teacher should
my boss should like everyone should what
about you
what are you doing yeah turn it on they
people are infatuated with that how
about [__] taking the word they out
of your mouth and saying I
how about that you want a good piece of
advice get where they out of your
[__] mouth on something you want
accomplished and go into I
change your life you hate politicians
become one yeah and win your race
Win Win It Be the mayor fix it
don't like how people are parenting that
kid over across the way just focus on
parenting your kid don't tell them what
to do they're not going to listen to you
anyway I'm not gonna hey Mr Jones I
don't like the way you're doing through
son Ronnie tell him to keep his bike off
you worry about your kids that's how
you're gonna fix it
that's [__] that [__]
Gary first of all thank you for
continuing to be a loud megaphone in the
space in the world we need it I love
this conversation I had so I can't wait
to go watch it again and get all things
I missed because I'm trying to you know
support people and yeah yeah I love the
engagement in the community you also had
some other questions I'm going to do
something really nice I'm gonna have you
send my team those questions and I'm
gonna do some split screen answers and
put it out on Twitter yeah or even
Instagram if it's real good yeah okay so
keep filling up the questions guys hey
Gary thank you can we do two SEC can we
go back to the live chat because I
always love that I just want to read a
couple things in there just want to see
what people are like thinking about or
what they're resonating to like the
instant you know the instant feedback is
just something like I always am curious
by that
it's very fun to watch everybody jumping
in and just taking some positivity into
the world go back to that one I suck at
sales that's great Tony there's no need
to be great at it like some people are
good at someone hire someone who does
sales you might be great at Ops I know
unlimited people you know unlimited
people that are great at sales yeah that
don't have a good business yep because
they can't operate out of a [__]
paper bag yep
you you like that one it's just real
right they can sell their ass off good
and if you don't know where the money
went you can't find it who gives a [__]
how much you sold like if you don't like
like people have strengths and
weaknesses Yep this is this is my uh
this is my boy Brayden hey Braden how do
you learn to love yourself that's a that
could be another two two day podcast and
we'll give these these questions dude
I'll send them by realizing the reason
you don't love yourself is that you
listen to somebody else
you want to real answer this question
I'm giving it to you hatch the re you
learn to love yourself because you take
a huge step backwards and realize the
reason you don't love yourself is that
you listened to someone else
normally a mother a father a grandparent
a sibling or a spouse or relationship
normally one of those 10 people
pound you out of their own hurts
so much that you believed them and it
became your own
yep
it's the truth it's the [__] truth
and we have to we have to have like the
better combo that's what I'm about right
now I'm like okay I got about another 50
here yeah I'm 47 in I'd like to get to a
hundo but I'll take anything in the 90s
on the record of God
um on the record uh
I gotta [__] for the next 43 to 50
years get as much of this out of like
the real [__] enough of like
like let's call it what it is yeah there
was there's a lot of hurt people and
they hurt their kids without even
realizing yeah it's not like your mom
woke up and like I can't wait to [__] up
Johnny tonight no yeah they don't even
realize they're doing it yeah
they're doing it like this don't trust
anyone out there that's right right
Johnny don't trust any of those videos
they're gonna try to hurt you because
they got hurt
and all of a sudden Johnny's like oh
[__]
and most kids I got very fortunate when
I got met with that and people have
influence in my life it was too late I
had the natural DNA in my mom's first
five or six years of parenting put me in
a place of like I didn't believe that
when grown-ups including family members
or teachers or other people of Authority
or had leverage with me when they were
saying the world's bad I'm like you're
[__] stupid and I was at like 11. I
remember actively believing that yep
family members tell and all my family
members came from Russia so they really
like were cynical and sad and hurt and
I'm like at the time I was like you're
stupid notice what I said you're stupid
now I'm like oh my God I feel so bad for
the aunts and uncles you grew up in
Russia of course you believe that
everybody yeah it was the one it wasn't
about it was like it was scary like
Russia was like North Korea people don't
get it yeah you can leave it was a jail
anyway
look my friend you gotta go yeah I know
you do if you're keep at guys keep
throwing in questions I'll get them over
to Gary's team he'll have a field day
with it but thank you dude it's been a
great time together I appreciate you so
much for being such an iconic podcast
Panther
um it's been a lot of fun it's been
great to be with your community and I
felt like today's we touched on some
really good stuff I liked it I loved it
I kind of want to like I think we're
gonna get like 25 clips from it you're
gonna be in a lot of content all right
my friends thank you wonderful day
foreign
[Music]